it's power rankings time the opportunity
for football fans to give me the finger
because they don't like where their team
is placed in a completely meaningless
list that people nevertheless can't get
enough of that's why i take the time to
do it every week of football season
this week we asked twitter for some
input to help shape the discussion as we
unveil
sort of i posted them yesterday pft but
unveiling for these purposes the
steelers at number one christopher the
last unbeaten team the new kings of the
hill they're holding off the chiefs at
number two i don't care if the chiefs
would beat the steelers and frankly i'm
not sure they would i guess they would
because the chiefs would be fully
engaged and motivated and focused and
that's when they beat the crap out of
good teams but for now steelers 6-0
number one what do you think well i i
have no problem with that now i have a
problem with what you just said that you
think the chiefs will beat the steelers
then you should put them number one
still
i mean that's that's where i want to go
what what the hell did you just say to
me mike florio but i mean i think your
thoughts right there i mean i i do think
they are one and two definitely either
way you want to put them i would put the
chiefs in one yeah i just think in that
game you know i think the chiefs are a
tough matchup for the the steelers they
have good pass protection so they'll be
able to at least slow down that pass
rush you know steelers secondary is good
but it's zone blitzes and things like
that where the pressure and the
combination of all that help the zone
coverages and i don't know if you know
zone coverage is you're not going to get
away with that against my homes and
company he's going to throw rifles right
through it so that's where i would go
with the chiefs i'm i'm with you there
but are you rethinking it have i changed
your mind there no no no you haven't
changed my mind i'm just i wish we could
see i know the steelers and the chiefs
play
the earliest we would see it is the
postseason and oh by the way there's a
guy now playing for the chiefs by the
name of levion bell which makes that
game even more amazing even more
intriguing if it would ultimately happen
uh how about uh question here this one
comes from sandor
well if the chiefs played the steelers
today who would win hell well we would
just kind of if they played right now i
think the chiefs would win just because
the chiefs find a way to get themselves
locked in motivated focused on great
opponents and uh you know if the
steelers were middle of the pack that's
when you'd have to worry about the
chiefs losing their focus but i i do
think the chiefs would win if they
played today so i don't know maybe i
should have made them yeah you should
have no it's okay i mean you made a
mistake it's all right you made them
over it is your website you can change
them isn't there something to be said
isn't there something to be said for
being undefeated there is this far into
this there definitely is there's no
doubt about that i mean there's a lot to
look at the pittsburgh steelers and you
could sit there and go no they are the
number one team in football i mean it's
it's not crazy to say that by any
stretch of the imagination you start to
go through their football team and you
just go well where's the weakness you
know we talked about like for a bunch of
weeks can you know when they get a lead
can they run out the clock you know what
about their offense it's iffy well
that's gone away i mean they've proved
to us they have found their formula for
what works for their football team so
they're really well-rounded and don't
have a lot of weakness there where i
want to ask you too here is was there
any thought
of making the buccaneers any higher
because
after last week again another dominant
performance against a pretty good team
in the raiders
i would have entertained maybe him
having them in front of the titans and
the ravens i know that's not easy to say
or do i probably would have put them in
front of the titans maybe behind the
ravens now that i sit here and just say
it out loud any thought there well look
at the split we have one two three four
afc teams five six seven eight
nfc teams i think the buccaneers are the
best team right now
in the nfc yeah the most complete team
by far in the nfc i just don't think
they're ready to crack the top four of
the afc i think those four teams
steelers chiefs titans ravens have
separated from the pack
and and here's the reality the ravens
and the steelers play each other this
weekend so
that's an opportunity for the buccaneers
when they beat the giants on monday
night to pop up yeah into that top four
right because maybe one of those two
teams is going to drop out after they
lose on on sunday yeah i mean you're
right you could have that opportunity
the steelers ravens game i can't wait
for that i mean that's going to be a
heavyweight battle there but yeah i
think the buccaneers i agree with you
are are the best team in the nfc you
know again you start to break them down
and the same thing we've been talking
about for the last two weeks there's
just not a lot of weakness to their team
there's not any area you can look at and
go oh
that's going to be an issue in december
or in the playoffs people are going to
take advantage of that eventually
they've been lucky with the schedule or
whatever that is i just don't see any
area to where no matter who they played
if they had to play the ravens i'd go
well buccaneers are big enough and they
can handle the run game of derrick henry
or lamar jackson and that they had to
play the chief said go well they can
rush the passer and their secondary is
good enough to hang in there with the
chiefs and all that stuff too to where
you know again i just the the buccaneers
continue to impress and uh i know you
got the packers and seahawks right there
but you know i would put them there too
as well but the saints of the other team
i've started to look at too to go oh
they're starting to look like to me
they're getting close to that second
best team in the nfc conversation too
i want to see more dominance from the
saints i agree in past regular seasons
you know to only beat the panthers by
three and to have to hold them off with
the sack that knocked them out of field
goal range and then sweating out the
65-yard field goal that was within maybe
two yards of going through and forcing
overtime right i remember the saints
from not all that long ago would just
show up put it away just just stuff them
in a in a locker and and leave yeah and
and that was that um
next question and this relates to the
four teams from the nfc
west seahawks at seven rams at 10
cardinals 11 49ers up to 15. a thomas
55. with all the nfc west in the top
half the league who do you see dropping
out since it's unlikely every one of
them finishes with a positive record
despite all being good teams look i
think they all can finish above 500
here's why they play all the teams of
the nfc east and they play all the teams
of the afc east they could all finish
with with winning records and they all
could make the playoffs chris right i i
agreed they they all could make the
playoffs they're all
i think playoff caliber teams you know i
mean and really let me just say this i
have no doubt
that the seahawks rams and 49ers are
playoff caliber teams i mean the way the
49ers have looked the last two weeks you
know again you'd start to think oh watch
out here they come to be one of those
top teams in the nfc once again here too
but you know i think to answer the
question specifically if you're going to
make me pick a team i'm still going to
pick arizona to be the team to drop out
but the biggest reason being
they really got the easy part of their
schedule done i'm just not sure what
they are yet you know you look at their
schedule they got the dolphins the bills
the seahawks the patriots the rams you
know the eagles the 49ers the rams and
the giants are all there i mean that's a
lot of tough football games and i guess
if you just made me pick one that would
be the team i would say falls out
and and let's play this out yeah a
little bit just for some fun here
okay let's say
that
the seahawks are the one seed they win
the division and they're the ones seed
so they don't play they're the only team
that doesn't play wild card with him
yeah so then you've got then you've got
and and again i'm just i'm throwing a
dart here but this isn't all that
implausible let's say the buccaneers are
the two seed
let's say the packers are the three seed
and whoever wins the nfc east is the
fourth let's say the eagles all right
okay let's say the eagles then let's say
just just for sake of argument the
cardinals are
the five seed okay the rams are the
sixth seed and the 49ers of the seventh
seed all right
49ers at bucks whoa
right out of the gates that's a
heavyweight battle right out of the
gates that's right right i mean that's
going to be a two two teams in the super
bowl playing each other in the wild card
right there exactly yeah and 49ers win
let's say 49ers win yeah let's say let's
say uh rams go to green bay
let's say rams it all clicks for sean
mcvay that day no doubt going against
going against uh one of his pupils yeah
in in matlab floor right rams win that
one and come on cardinals going to
philly come on you can have all four
teams in the nfc west
not just in the playoffs but in the
division the seahawks get the one seed
you can have all four nfc west teams in
the final four wasn't there a year i
think like it was 85 the year that
villanova beat georgetown weren't there
three of four big east teams it was
three out of four was it all four no i
i'm in the final four yeah it was
something like that but you're right it
was it was something similar to that but
yeah i mean
you know it's this is some damn
conference it's got good quarterbacks
good coaches playmakers on both sides of
the ball with all these teams and i mean
that would be
really really amazing it really would be
and i don't think it's that it's not a
crazy it's not a crazy thought that's
the thing the crazier thought is all for
making it right if all four make it it's
not crazy if the seahawks are the one
seed obviously no it's not crazy to
think that all four would be left
standing after the wild card round no it
would not be crazy i guess the only
thing i looked at where you just
mentioned all those teams and all that
the only thing i just want to go away
but then the saints aren't in it you
know and i just i still have a hard time
not putting the saints in it but again
like you've said it has not been as
dominant they are letting teams hang
around
and we'll see where that goes but it's
not as crazy as you're you know it's not
crazy it's not but but you know that's
an excellent point that undermines the
opportunity for all of them to make it
the only way all of them make it is if
none of the second place teams
hold it together the bears are in the
process of having to fall apart right
and and either the saints or the bucks
would have to fall apart and right now
as you said they're both showing signs
that that they're pretty damn good which
which means
there could be a fourth place team in
the nfc west it could be good enough to
run the table that isn't going to get a
seat at the table yeah this year
all right uh teams outside the top ten
hot blog sports which of the teams
ranked outside of your current top ten
have a legitimate shot at the super bowl
i mean we just talked about the 49ers at
number 15. if they continue to play the
way they have the last two weeks
and they've got the seahawks this
weekend
you know they're a team that that
because they did it last year because
they they got hit in the mouth so early
this year
and basically had to forget completely
about last year and had to do kind of
the hard reset and we're gonna have to
do it a different way it's gonna be a
lot harder path than last year
i still could i mean it wouldn't stun me
if if you know the way that kyle
shanahan is doing it now it wouldn't
stun me right if if they could get it
from out of the top 10 and get to the
super bowl yeah i mean i i agreed i
think the 49ers still watch out for them
there's there's still too many elite
things about their football team too and
you know i know that you you talked
earlier in the show about that dolphins
game yeah that was a bad one you know
hey they outplayed the cardinals in week
one kind of blew it they definitely
outplayed the eagles and nick mullen as
we've talked about crapped all over his
leg all right so that that ruined that
game you know so the record's a hair
misleading and i think they are getting
healthy and you say start to say watch
out and even that nick bosa and stuff
you see their defense is still
very talented still a really good
defensive line
and linebackers are phenomenal and like
you said the shanahan aspect and then
being able to run the ball and debo
samuel and ayuk and kittle and if
mozdert's healthy i mean that's as good
of a four-man skill guy as you can find
in football and they can do everything i
mean the damn tight end can run speed
sweeps like debo samuel and a brian
brandon ayoke ayuk so uh i would say
watch out for them the other team i
would just say right outside of your top
ten that i'm i'm still
you know got a little something on there
as i said the colts because of that
defense and that old line
and frank wright being creative and
philip rivers can make plays you know i
know he can mess it up too i would still
hold out to them as one of those teams
that go
they have some playoff super bowl ish
type traits to their football team to
where the right matchups arise in the
playoffs
who knows maybe they could get in
let's take a look beyond the top 16 and
an important question from rich
oh no before that
um
the patriots yeah at number 17.
and and a question raised by pete in the
in the sheets we use to communicate with
each other is this the first time that
the patriots have been out of the top
half in the history of the pft power
rankings and you know what
it probably is the first time i mean
we've been doing them since the early
days of the website and other than
2002
when they finished nine and seven and
you're still going to be in the top half
with a 9-7 record you're just not a
playoff team this probably is the first
time and i gave them the benefit of the
doubt yeah so long right and i kept
thinking you know this team is far
better than the record suggests and you
know what you lose that badly at home
and look that badly
with three interceptions and cam newton
just whatever's wrong with him i don't
know that it's fixable quickly you're
not going to stay in the top half you're
at the very top of the bottom half but
you're not staying in the top half chris
yeah i mean i got no prop problem with
that the way they played yeah there's
issues there cam newton's not been
smooth i mean the lack of practice all
the disruption they've had i i i don't
look at any teams that you have
above them right now
for where i sit there and just go oh
they're definitely better than them
right now at this second i know they
beat the raiders a few weeks ago but
that was a long long damn time ago and
the patriots aren't playing as good as
they were then and the raiders even
though they got a tough loss last week
against the buccaneers there's still
things that you look at are positive
there so
i'm with you this will be a big week for
the patriots to see where they're at and
i don't know maybe if they lose this
week maybe they will change their mantra
maybe they just go okay it's not going
to happen this year maybe we need to
just to start thinking about next year i
have a hard time believing that
and i like i've said i think the bills
they match up really well if they can
steal that game and win
then i'd start to perk up a little bit
and go watch out for the patriots
question from at rule 16 jack if you had
to assign percentages as to why the
patriots offense stinks how would you
divide it up between
cam newton not playing well
offensive coordinator josh mcdaniels and
overall lack of talent around newton
well i would go probably overall lack of
talent then followed by cam newton not
playing well i guess that would probably
be the top thing you know give me the
pie chart give me the pie chart give me
percentages has to add up to 100. well
okay i mean the way it is right now i
would go more of like um
not top end talent you know that would
probably be 55 to 60 of the problem you
know somewhere in there and then i'd go
okay 60 of the problems that and then
the last few weeks yeah 20
to
cam newton and then
the offensive line you know being a
mishmash the first week back
and mcdaniels and the game plan and
belichick and all that okay i'll give
them the remaining 15 to 20 but that's
kind of how i would look at it that way
you know again
when they get down the way they got down
last week it's over they don't have the
team that can do that they don't you
know i know people saw them do that
against the seattle seahawks but the
seattle seahawks defense is the worst in
football and maybe the worst we've seen
in a long long time so
that that's where they're really stuck
they have to be able to run the ball and
be effective there and that helps their
passing game and they haven't been able
to get into that mode uh a lot the last
few weeks
rich south 72 with a topic that we're
going to delve into a little more deeply
in the next segment as it relates to
trevor lawrence but he asks this
question do you think the patriots are
tanking to get trevor lawrence well damn
they got a lot of tanking to do that's
for sure because they're going to have
some competition and no i don't i don't
know
yeah two wins two wins disqualifies you
from the trevor lawrence sweepstakes i
mean really it's looking like you know
yeah the jets have a chance to
definitely go 016 and be that first pick
but i i don't think they're tanking i
don't look at it that way nope uh i
don't expect them to and
i don't know i mean again i don't expect
them to be anywhere near the top one
top pick in the draft to where i can't
imagine them trading or doing stuff like
that to go get one player i just don't
think that's their belief they're never
a team that thinks oh one player is
going to make us better they build teams
and then they try to get the quarterback
in there they feel like fits the team
how it's built that way and let's work
from there so i would be shocked if they
win it all in on a trevor lawrence type
of play
and i think the idea of having that one
guy that becomes the focal point face
the franchise right out of the gates i
don't think they want that i don't think
they
they they
they try to create an environment where
that doesn't exist although it's
impossible with tom brady around for it
not to happen after all the super bowl
wins right all right another question
from is there a question here henry
chapman
are the cowboys are the cowboys not at
least how are the cowboys not at least
30th i genuinely think they couldn't
beat the jets based off the past couple
of weeks and you know the the cowboys
are the nfc's answer to the jets a bad
team that isn't competitive i mean the
giants are bad their record is worse
but the giants are at least competitive
right now the cowboys chris aren't
competitive no they're not um i i would
probably agree with your buddy or
whoever that is that answered that
question and go oh i think the cowboys
are very worthy of the 30 or 31st team
in the rankings you know it's it's tough
sledding down here they're all not good
but if the cowboys had to play deshaun
watson and the texans i'm taking deshaun
watson and the texans and i'm taking
gardner minshew and the jaguars over the
cowboys too there ain't nothing to look
at and go oh the cowboys will beat them
you know the only team i'll look at
would go
jets
okay they'll win i i think i'm not even
like totally positive but i think
they'll win and i mean especially right
now with dinucci at quarterback and all
that i think that's a that's a coin toss
so i probably would have made the
cowboys 31 mike
i you know what i should have made them
30. i should have made them 30 in
hindsight but you know they beat the
giants and they have a better record
than the giants and i get and and and
here look this is self-preservation
i didn't want
50 emails
from all the the salty cowboys fans out
there who are clinging to i don't know
what at this point maybe they've all
given up vince our good buddy who likes
to send hostile emails anytime we don't
talk
favorably about the cowboys you know but
if you put the cowboys behind the giants
you you are walking into
an argument that cowboys beat the giants
cowboys have more wins how are the
cowboys not
i know i know well jack prescott played
most of that game against the cowboy i
mean the giants and that just you know
hey they were fortunate to win but
they're not that same team now so that's
where you could justify it and just
email them all and go screw off your
team stinks
here's the thing
when you're down to the low 20s if
you're arguing positioning there
uh you got far bigger problems than
whether you're 28 29 or 30. weird number
29
yes
all right uh three win teams the raiders
at 16 the dolphins at 18 the panthers at
19 and the lions at 22.
which one
is a true contender for the rest of the
season
i think the well no i'm not going to say
that i'm going to say the raiders right
right off the bat that they're going to
be when we say contender like in that
playoff conversation hey they play hard
every week
you know their offense has weapons they
can run the ball
you know their defensive line is really
the biggest issue on their football team
but i'll look at them
you know i can't say the dolphins as
much as i like a lot of things i just i
got to see two a play got to see two of
them yeah i can't buy into that quite
yet
you know panthers man i like i think i'm
still going to go with the raiders if i
have to pick any of those football teams
i'm going to go with the raiders out of
those four but the panthers and lions
certainly make me think a little bit
i thought you were going to say you
picked the raiders because they're on
the cutting edge of beating the virus
they're destroying it it's gone in all
seriousness no that's one of the reasons
why i wouldn't pick the raiders because
of all the incidents they've had and
you've got a coach who is delusional
about it which shows he's learned
nothing about it and you have to assume
there may be another game this year
where
they've got guys who aren't available to
practice they still have to go forward
with the game and they're going to lose
and maybe lose badly and at some point
you have enough of those bad losses that
you just aren't a contender anymore i
think the panthers i like what i've seen
from the panthers they're getting
christian mccaffrey back soon maybe as
soon as tomorrow night teddy bridgewater
has looked great but for that late sack
that he took that knocked them out of
field goal range i mean they gave the
saints all they can handle so i'll take
the panthers and uh that that's a team
that
that could be very dangerous
by the time january rolls around if you
let them in if you give them a seat at
the table and they've got nothing to
lose
that's a that's a team that you don't
want to mess around with when the
postseason rolls around all right last
comments not really question ct gabe
the jets at number 32 are way too hot
they need to be relegated
i used to do it
you know it gets old fast but i would
put like the best college team at 32 and
then the worst nfl team at 33 but you
know you can only do that once or twice
before it gets yeah it becomes cliche
but yeah relegate them to the cfl or uh
or the xfl the xfl is coming back next
year maybe the jets should be the first
team in the xfl
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports